a person wanted to know why is everyone
getting shingles nowadays i mean it seems
like everyone's getting shingles now that's
a bit of an exaggeration but there definitely
is an increase in the amount of people
getting shingles now what is shingles
it's a virus it's called herpes zoster and it's
a virus that remains dormant for many many years
and then it can come out and create all sorts of
pain and misery especially on the surface of the
skin that follows nerves around your rib cage it
can come up through your back through the front
in fact it can become so painful certain people
become suicidal so it's a really big deal normally
one and a half to 2.5 people out of a thousand
will get shingles okay but between 2000 and 2007
three of a thousand people are getting it so it's
definitely going up and there's even a higher
incidence of people getting shingles in certain
areas of the country which i'm going to talk about
so you have a situation where this virus is
in a dormant stage and it's just waiting there
it's not doing anything it's waiting for the
right environment so that it can come out
and create a lot of discomfort for you has to
do with how healthy your immune system is if
there's anything suppressing your immune system
that's when it comes out so again the topic of
viruses come down to your own immune system
is it healthy is it weak it's an area that
not many people emphasize but it's not until
your immune system gets weakened or suppressed
that this virus then comes out and creates the
problem so let's talk about what can trigger
this virus coming out of remission number
one drugs for cancer drugs for asthma
prednisone drugs for autoimmune diseases all will
suppress your immune system number three radiation
has a strong effect of bringing this virus out
of remission so how are you exposed to radiation
well you can get an x-ray or what about sun why
is it that the majority of outbreaks of shingles
occur during the summer months is because of the
sun so more sun more radiation more outbreaks
stress can be a big factor in whether this
virus comes out of remission a poor diet lack of
nutrients lack of sleep and number seven and this
is why i'm doing this video this is an extra thing
that i didn't know before i found some interesting
research on it so i wanted to share it with you
pesticides and insecticides yes those have a
direct effect on weakening your immune system
and unfortunately guess what's been going up
in recent years more exposure to pesticides
and insecticides so we're just going to add
another thing to the list to help you keep these
pesticides out of your body so number one this is
what i'm going to recommend if you have shingles
do fasting very very important it's going to help
you number two vitamin d probably about between
40 and 50 000 iu's because you need a very strong
natural thing that acts like cortisol to actually
put this thing back in remission but not sun
even though the sun helps you activate vitamin d
i'm going to recommend getting the vitamin d
directly from a supplement and not getting the
radiation because vitamin d will help but we don't
need the radiation in this situation number three
vitamin c in this case i would take higher amounts
like a thousand milligrams three times a day
number four zinc i probably take anywhere
between 50 to 100 milligrams of zinc number five
l-lysine number six melatonin and number seven to
pull out these pesticides i would start consuming
more cruciferous vegetables and the one i
would eat more of would be radishes okay
radishes have a very potent effect at creating the
detox that you need to pull out these pesticides
and insecticides and of course start eating
organic as well because that's going to be
vitally important all right thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next video
hey before you go if you're benefiting
from any of my content i would love
to hear about your success story
please share it in the link down below